[موسيقى]
من سفر اشعياء الذي يعتبر نصا رئيسيا من
الكتاب المقدس عند اليهود العهد القديم
نقرا لكم ليمت جميع الناس ويحيى اسرائيل
وحده يرفعك الله فوق جميع شعوب الارض
ويجعلك الشعب المختار ويقف الاجانب يرعون
اغنام اما انتم بني اسرائيل فتدعو كهنه
الرب تسمون خدام الهنا وعلى مجدهم
تتامر الى
العناوين اسرائيل تستنسخ داعش وتتحول الى
دافن كاميرا القسام تصل الى خيامهم في
المشهد
الاخير نتنياهو يفرح
بمحاصيل السنوار
الفارغ رئيس اركان الاحتلال موضع شك لدى
الحكومه خبير عسكري اسرائيلي حماس
انتصرت ماكرون يحول قصر الاليزيه الى كنيس
يهودي مسلسل استهداف عائلات مرا الجزيره
[موسيقى]
متواصل اسمحوا لي بدايه ان ابدا بخبر شخصي
فقد وعدني بهيج بانه اذا اصبح مديرا لشبكه
الجزيره سوف يهدين مركبه فضائيه اتجول
فيها بين الكواكب كذلك وعدت اسرائيل
الغزيين بانها اذا احتلت قطاعهم سوف تحوله
الى جنه على الارض والدل ل الضفه الغربيه
المحتله مرحبا اشتغلت اسرائيل على مدى
سنوات مدعومه بمئات ملايين الدولارات
الامريكيه لتشويه سمعه المقاومه ووصمها
بالارهاب حتى باتت تصف المقاومين مؤخرا
بالدواعش
لتخطف اللقب فجاه بجداره من داعش الاصليه
وتقول انا دافن دال ال فء نون دوله
اسرائيل من الفرات الى النيل مشروع التخرج
الدافن تقدمه اسرائيل الان بحمله الاباده
في غزه اما عن اختطاف اللقب بالصوره فقد
اعادت اسرائيل تمثيل مشهد وضع داعش اسرعها
تحت فوهات اسلحتها مع فارق ان اسرائيل عرت
الاسرى المدنيين من ثيابهم في مخالفه لكل
الشرائع والقوانين الدوليه صور ومقطع مصور
لعشرات الفلسطينيين من غزه يتم اقتيادهم
عرات في اجواء بارده الى مراكز اعتقال
اسرائيليه يجلسون في شارع بملابسهم
الداخليه السفليه وحولهم عدد من الجنود
الاسرائيليين ولماذا تمت تعريه الاسرى
يسال مستشار نتنياهو فيجيب بان الجو حار
ان جحشي لهدا الرجل انه عمل مستشار لبيبي
نتنياهو اذا كان الجو حارا في غزه فلماذا
احرق جنود الغفله اطنانا من اغذيه
وبطانيات
للتدفئه وهل مكتوب على دافعي الضرائب
الامريكيين ان يتعبوا ويفن بابهم من اجل
تسليات جنود الاحتلال الليليه في موقف
دافني اصيل دعا ارييه كينج نائب رئيس
بلديه الاحتلال في القدس الى دفن الاسرى
الفلسطينيين المدنيين في قطاع غزه وهم
احياء لترهيب الناس التي اثبتت انها لا
تخاف الا رب الناس ام فلسطينيه اقوى من كل
ملكات التاريخ تقود عرب كارو يجرها بغل او
حمار تحمل عليها شهيدا وجريحا من ابنائها
تحاول اخراجه ما من جحيم القصف الاسرائيلي
على خان يونس لدفن الشهيد واسعاف الجريح
هي شهدا كمان هي شهدا لا حول ولا قوه الا
[موسيقى]
بالله الاكاديمي الكويتي المعروف جاسم
الجزاع يتحدث عما يصفه بتكريس التلمود
ازدراء البشر من غير اليهود شوف الان مثل
نتنياهو ذاك اليوم يتكلم عن امور مذكوره
حتى في التلمود وقال التلمود كذا اول نقطه
مثل ما قال الوزير الدفاع مش انا وزير
الدفاع الحالي قال كل هذه من التعاليم
الموجوده في اليهوديه في تلمود كل ما سوى
اليهود نطفته حصان قذرا لولا اليهود ما
خلقت الارض ولا السماء ولا يستحق الحياه
الابديه الا اليهود اما باقي الخلق فهم
[__] ويقولون شوف الكلمه الغريبه هذه
يقولون اليهودي افضل من الكلب والكلب افضل
من غير اليهودي فان اردت ان تسقي احدهما
فاسقي الكلب ولا تسقي غير اليهودي يجيز
التلمود ان تزني بغير اليهوديه لانه غير
يهوديه فلا ينطبق عليها القانون البشري
الذي يحترم الذوات البشريه هل هذه عقيده
كل اليهود في العالم كلا فهذا حاخام يهودي
امريكي اسمه دفيد فيلدمان يتمنى على
الجميع التمييز بين دوله الاحتلال اسرائيل
هذا وصفه لها واليهود غير
الصهاينه الحاخام دفيد يشعر بالعار اذاء
محرقه غزه التي ترتكب باسم اليهود يقول ما
يجري في غزه جريمه اباده قتل الالاف من
النساء والرجال والاطفال الابرياء هناك
يجب ان نقف ضد كل هذه الجرائم اشعر بالعار
يظهر ديننا اليهودي كمسؤول عن هذه الاحداث
ولكن هذا كله خطا كبير دوله اسرائيل لا
تمثل اليهود يجب ان يعارض كل يهودي هذه
الجرائم نحتاج الى وقف اطلاق النار وليس
فقط هدنه يجب علينا الحديث عن هذا
الاحتلال الذي استمر لعقود يجب ان يتوقف
والى الابد في الفقه الاسلامي لا تجوز
الصلاه على ارض لم ياذن لك صاحبها بالصلاه
فيها الدوافه يحول منازل
الفلسطينيين الى كنس يهوديه في غزه وفي
نفس الوقت يهدمون مساجد المسلمين وكنائس
المسيحيين هدمته الحملات الصليبيه ثم
الغزو المغولي والان يهدمه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اعاد المماليك بناءه مرتين بعد
طرد المحتلين فمن سيعيد اعماره هذه المره
يا ترى الجامع العمري الاثري الكبير
في غزه هدمت اجزاء من المسجد وتحول الى
كنيسه في سنوات الاحتلال الصليبي لبيت
المقدس ثم اعاد المماليك بنائه في القرن
الثال عشر الميلادي غير ان بناء المماليك
هدم تماما على يد المغول قبل ان يعيد
بناءه سنقر العلائي من ولاه المماليك ايضا
بعد سنوات من هدمه توحش اله القتل
الاسرائيليه على الاهداف المدنيه والاطفال
مرده ق ر يدها عن المقاومين يقال كتائب
القسام تنتهك خصوصيه الجنود وتصورهم داخل
خيامهم قبل تفجيرها بهم لكن ان تصل لتوثيق
عمليه رصد خيام تمركز جنود الاحتلال فيها
قبل زرع عبوات ناسفه فيها وتفجيرها فهذا
ما راه البعض انه وصل حد انتهاك الخصوصيه
لجنود جيش الاحتلال الذي يصف نفسه بانه
اكثر جيوش العالم قوه وسريه وامنا في
المقابل كانت الكاميرا الاسرائيليه تشتغل
على تصوير فيلم اكشن لكنه تحول الى كوميدي
بما عرف بمعركه ذات الحيطان او ذات
الجدران فقد اشتبك جدود الاحتلال تحت
الكاميرات مع حيطان هامده وتمكنوا من
الحاق الاضرار فيها واحداث فج
بها علما انه كان بامكانهم الدخول من
الابواب
[موسيقى]
المفتوحه فان هذا المقطع الذي نشره جيش
الاحتلال لما قال انه قتال مباشر لقواته
مع كتائب القسام باحد ابنيه حي الشجاعيه
ففي الحقيقه صور مدرسه تابعه للنور ويظهر
فيه جليا اشتباك قواته مع لا احد فلا هدف
واضحا سوى الحائط ولا تمركزهم فيه احتماء
من رد محتمل قد ياتي من الجبهه المقابله
فالمكان فارغ والقتال وهمي والمخرج يبدو
انه نسي التركيز على تلك التفاصيل
الاسكندر النتن ياهي يتباهى بنصر مظفر اخر
احرزه ايضا على الحيطان فقد حاصر جنوده
جدران منزل رئيس حماس في غزه يحيى السنوار
الخالي تماما من اي كائن حي ومكثوا امامه
طويلا فهل ترك السنوار رساله لهم على
الباب نعود بعد
الصلاه بصوره المتباهي نشر رئيس الحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو فيلما يعلن فيه عن محاصره
الجيش الاسرائيلي منزل زعيم حركه حماس
يحيى السنوار في غزه في خطوه اثارت التهكم
والحيره لدى المحللين الذين طرحوا تساؤلات
كثيره بشان جدوى تصريح كهذا كلنا نعرف ان
السنوار ليس في منزله لماذا يخلق حماسه لا
فائده منها مع شعور كما لو اننا وصلنا الى
السنوار عندما بدات اسمع المستوى السياسي
يتحدث بمصطلحات صوره نصر مقتل السنوار
وغيره بدات بالقلق لان هذا هو الخطا تماما
الذي ارتكبه في الجولات القتاليه السابقه
دبابه تكلف مع طاقمها وتشغيلها مئات الوف
الدولارات على المكلف الامريكي فياتي
مقاوم ابن الارض بجينز صنع في غزه او بادي
داس صنع في الصين ليحرق تلك الدبابه بمن
فيها فيطير المقاوم فرحا مع صرخه ولعت
اشتعلت الدبابه التي ظن صانعوها انها عصيه
على التفحم الله اكبر الله اك الله
اكبرك في هذا الوقت كان جندي اشوس ينتقم
من العاب الاطفال وكتبهم في مكتبه
[موسيقى]
غزاويه 740
رئيس اركان جيش الاحتلال هرتس هاليفي
المؤتمن على مصير اسرائيل الامني والعسكري
لا ياتمن نتنياهو على سر حراس رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي يفتشون اغراض رئيس
اركان الجيش قبل دخوله اجتماع مجلس الح
للتاكد من عدم حمله جهاز تسجيل هذه الخطوه
غير الاخلاقيه لو جرت في دوله طبيعيه لحلت
الحكومه على الفور قبل احاله رئيس الحكومه
ورئيس الاركان الى التحقيق بحثا عن جهاز
تسجيل افراد حراسه نتنياهو يفتشون اغراض
رئيس اركان الجيش قبل اجتماع مجلس الحرب
دراسه اجراها استاذ علم النفس في جامعه تل
ابيب شاؤول كمخيم على تحليل سلوك نتنياهو
الذي ابلغ عنه علنا في كتبه وعلى الاخبار
التي نشرت عنه في الصحف الاسرائيليه صفه
غياب المصداقيه تلازمه اذ يقدم نتنياهو
بحسب شهادات من حوله وعودا لا يفي بها
ويعد بحسب شهادات رؤساء امريكيين سابقين
غير جدير بالثقه واخيرا تغلب على نتنياهو
صفه الشك والارتياب ويسيطر عليه الشعور
بعداء الاخرين له وبانه ضحيه ويميل لتفسير
الاحداث انها ضده ويعممها على المجتمع
فيما يرى دائما في اصدقائه خونه محتملين
5000 جريح الفا معوق وست جريحا كل يوم
معظمهم اصابته خطره يحصي اعلام عبري هذه
الارقام لجيش الاحتلال في معاركه البريه
هذا ما سمح بنشره
اما الحقيقه فلا يعلمها الا الله ثم عمال
الدفن في المقابر العسكريه وطواقم
المستشفيات الاسرائيليه واصحاب مستودعات
الحفاضات في تل ابيب افادت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه بان 5000 جندي اسرائيلي جرحوا
منذ السابع من اكتوبر وان وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه اعتبرت ان 2000 منهم قد
اصيبوا بالاعاقه واشارت الى ان قسم اعاده
التاهيل في الوزاره يستقبل يوميا 60 جريحا
معظمهم اصاباتهم خطيره جنود الاحتلال العم
بعيون هذا ما اعلنته رئيسه مكتب الصحه في
هيئه البث الاسرائيليه مؤكده اصابه نحو
100 منهم بالعمى بعيون في معارك غزه اعلنت
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان نحو 100 من
جنود القوات الاسرائيليه وضباطها اصيبوا
في اعينهم خلال الحرب الدائره في غزه
15% منهم ادت اصاباتهم للعمى في احدى
العينين او كلتيهما ووفقا للاذاعه
الاسرائيليه فان سبب تعدد اصابات العيون
وكثرتها الشداء واصابات الطلقات الناريه
كما ان بعض الاصابات حدث لان الجنود لم
يرتدوا نظارات واقيه فيما يبقى المتسبب
الاكبر المواجهه من المسافه صفر نتنياهو
معجوق كيف بده يهجر الفلسطينيين بالنووي
وهم مصرون على البقاء في ارضهم فيما
جماعته هرب منهم نصف مليون حتى الان خوفا
من صواريخ المقاومه يلي عاملين بمصنع
حديده بغزه غزه تضرب عمود خيمه مشروع
الاحتلال ومنذ طوفان الاقصى 470 ال يهودي
غادروا فلسطين المحتله ولم يعودوا الى
اهالي الاسرى الاسرائيليين في قطاع غزه
رساله من خبير اسرائيلي مقرب من نتن ياه
ابنائكم الاسرى ليسوا اولويه على اجنده
حكومه تل ابيب تحير الرهائن ليس هدفا
استراتيجيا وهدفا انسانيا الهدف
الاستراتيجي من الحرب هو استئصال المنظمات
الارهابيه وبالتالي هنا تكمل المعضله نحن
من الممكن ان نتفاوض على تحرير الرهائن
بشكل تدريجي تحرير عدد من الرهائن ولكن في
نهايه المطاف نحن لن نضحي بالانجازات التي
احرزنا حتى الان وبمصير العمليات العسكريه
بالنسبه للخصم او العدو في مقابل طبعا
تحيق ال مائير المصري يريد استثمار
انتصارات الجيش في غزه لكن مايرا اخر هو
برهان مائير لديه اقوال اخرى علينا ان
نعترف بان حماس قد انتصرت وان الاستمرار
في المكابره سوف يؤدي الى السقوط الكبير
للجيش الاسرائيلي
يقول
دواف فرنسيون واوروبي مرتزقه يقاتلون في
غزه مع جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الذي لا
يحصي قتلاهم
وجرحاهم المهم ان المرتزق منهم يتقاضى
4000 دولار في الاسبوع هلا ليش ما بيعطوه
راتب شهري لانهم ما بيتوقع انه يعيش كثير
في المقابل جماعه الشبشب والادي دس
التاليد بغزه ينتظرونهم على احر من
الياسين 105 يقال استقدام الجيش
الاسرائيلي مرتزقه اوروبيين وغربيين مقابل
4000 دولار في الاسبوع تحقيق تنشره صحيفه
الموندو الاسبانيه قبل حذفه جراء الضغوط
السياسيه ملف خطير يحمله محامون الى
المحاكم
الاوروبيه المختصه الملف ليس سريا والعديد
من الجهات تتحدث عنه لكن الادله الان
تتكاثر رغم محاولات التستر والتعتيم
الغربيه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الاسبق
ايهود اولمرت الذي لا يستطيع السفر الى
كثير من دول اوروبا وغيرها خشيه اعتقاله
بتهمه ارتكاب جرائم حرب بحق
الفلسطينيين لم يعد قادرا على تحمل منسوب
الاجرام لدى بنيامين نتنياهو وتامار بنفير
وبقيه طاوله اباده لانهم برايه يشكلون
خطرا على بقاء
اسرائيل national historical disaster for
israel he has to go
ben terrible event
sm
event in territor in
west call
enem
جوول المسؤول المستقيل من وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه يفاجئ ربعه بانهم يدعمون مغتصبي
الاطفال الاسرى ان كانوا لا يعلمون الحركه
الدوليه للدفاع عن اطفال فلسطين لفتت وفدا
امريكيا كان جوش بول ضمنه الى حالات
اغتصاب اطفال من قبل للجادين الاسرائيليين
في المعتقلات
الامريكيون ابلغوا حكومه تلبيب فنفت
الجمعيه الحقوقيه كيانا ارهابيا وصادرت
ارشيف
[موسيقى]
لا تستطيع ان تطالب بانهاء احتلال في مكان
ما وانت تدعم احتلالا في مكان اخر يؤكد
رئيس الوزراء القطري الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحم ال ثاني خلال منتدى الدوحه الدولي
اظهرت هذه الازمه بوضوح حجم الفجوه بين
الشرق والغرب وبين الاجيال المتعاقبه
وازدواجيه المعايير في المجتمع الدولي حيث
انقسم العالم الى مطالب بانهاء هذه الحرب
وايقاف اله القتل ومتردد حتى في مجرد
الدعوه الى وقف اطلاق النار
ونرى من كان يطالب بوقفه عالميه ضد
الاحتلال في سياق اخر اخر يرفض اليوم مجرد
ادانه جرائم احتلال الاراضي الفلسطينيه
ويقف عائقا امام التوافق الدولي على
ايقافها اكثر شيء بيزعج بهيج بالولايات
المتحده مش انسان بل تمثال تمثال الحريه
في دوله تفعل المستحيل من اجل منع الحريه
عن
الفلسطينيين ام الانسانيه المدخنه تحبط
بالفيتو مشروع قرار لوقف النار في مجلس
الامن الدولي مجددا ترفع الولايات المتحده
يدها دعما لحليفها الكيان الصهيوني حيث
استخدمت للمره الثانيه حق النقض لاجهاض
قرار بمجلس الامن الدولي لوقف اطلاق النار
في قطاع غزه متجاهله جرائم الاحتلال في حق
الفلسطينيين نائب المندوب الروسي لدى
الامم المتحده يعلن باللغه العربيه ان
موسكو لا تقبل بنكب جديده في
فلسطين عزيزي انتم لا تستطيعون وقف الحرب
على غزه لكنكم تستطيعون اكراما لاطفال غزه
وقف قتل اقراهم واخوانهم اطفال سوريا بمنع
قصف المدنيين في ادلب اصدقائنا العرب
الاعزاء تضى روسيا الى وقف خلقه العنف اثر
التصيد اسرائيلي الفلسطيني الذي نشده منذ
الب
اكتوبر كما نضم صوتنا الى العديد من
النداءات لوق اطلاق النار المستدام الرئيس
ايمانويل ماكرون يلي دو خراص المسلمين
الفرنسيين بقيم الجمهوريه العلمانيه حول
قصر الرئاسه الاليزيه الى كنيس يهودي لبعض
الوقت وذلك لاقامه الطقوس الدينيه بعيد
الحانوكا وقد لعب الاب ايمانويل كما وصف
دور مساعد
الحاخام الاعياد المسيحيه على الابواب
فهل يجرؤ ماكرون على اقامه قداس كاثوليكي
في قصر الاليزيه اثار الاحتفال بعيد
الانوار اليهودي والمعروف باسم عيد هانوكا
في قصر الاليزي وبحضور الرئيس ماكرون موجه
كبيره من الجدل في صفوف المعارضه وقال
النائب اليكسي كوربيه بان احتضان الاليزي
لمناسبه الامس بمثابه خرق واضح للعلمانيه
في فرنسا وكذلك قال عمده مدينه كان من
جهتها دافعت رئيسه الحكومه الفرنسيه عن
مناسبه الامس مشيره الى انها رساله دعم
قويه من الرئيس ماكرون ضد معاداه الساميات
في البلاد نازم
[موسيقى]
زم المستشار الالماني اولاف شولتس كان
اكثر استعدادا من ماكرون للاحتفال بعيد
الحنوكه فقد اعتمر القلنسوه اليهوديه
واشعل الشمعدان في قلب برلين فما هذا
الهوس غير المسبوق باسرائيل
تاعتها zle schen wir die jd gemen hier
in
deutschland dass dies nach den terror
der h und den reaktion darf n ist ist
traurig und erschrecken
[موسيقى]
zle
شركه زاره الاسبانيه لبي الالبسه هل تحولت
الى بي الاكفان الملطخه بالدماء وتحديدا
دماء الابرياء في غزه الشركه خاطرت قبل
تعتذر بفقدان مئات ملايين الزبائن الاحرار
فقط من اجل ارضاء اسرائيل فشه قزاره يازار
تعلق سيده لبنانيه شركه زاره للملابس
عالميه عم تروج عندها بالصفحه الخاصه
اعلان استخفافا باهل فلسطين مثل ما شايفين
قدامكم بالصور جسس مكفنه بيت مهدوم خريطه
فلسطين كل هيدا مقصود لحتى يجوا يستخف
باهل
[موسيقى]
فلسطين احمد
مدرستنا وحد الله اناس وحد الله ايش
فيذ وحد الله فيش عند
السبب
بينس هكذا كانت الصوره للحظات وداع مراسل
الجزيره في غزه انس الشريف والده الشهيد
الذي قتل بقصف اسرائيلي مؤمن الشرافي وانس
الشريف بعد وائل الدحدوح مراسل شبكه
الجزيره في غزه يدفع مع شعبهم اثمان
الثبات في الارض مؤمن كغيره من ذوي
الشهداء لم يستطع تكريم الاهل نحن نحرم من
نظره الوداع الاخيره للوالد والوالده
والاخ
والاخت ابن الاخت
والاطفال نحن نحرم من دفنهم بكرامه
ايضا نتيجه الحصار الاسرائيلي ومنع سكان
المنطقه الجنوبيه او من نزحوا المنطقه
الجنوبيه مجبرين الى العوده الى الشمال
لدفن اشقائهم ابائهم امهاتهم خالاتهم
اقاربهم احبائهم ليس المطلوب من
الاعلاميين الاسرائيليين ان يكونوا مهنيين
او
انساني لكن قليلا من الحياء امام الكاميرا
تولو روتم اخي هون مذيعه اسرائيليه تفرغ
حقدها بقلمها توقع به على صواريخ ستقتل
حتما في الغالب الاطفال والنساء وتصيح
باسلوب فاحش لنقص الان جعل الله ديارك
عامره بما تحبينه لديار الابرياء في غزه
دعاء
س
[موسيقى]
2 كل
كبود وت
خفشي كنت بتحكي عن ابو عبيده باقي شيء
لانه ابو عبيده ده قصه اه 20 23 ينفتل
الناس
بمنقبه انا برضو انا بسال
نفسي يعني هي لتتن المتكرر يستفز المشاهد
والمشاهده سامحونا واجبنا ان نستفز لانعمل
العقل هذا كان المذيع اما الضيف الذي عرف
عنه بانه روائي فكان روايه بحد ذاته هم
اشكالهم مختلفه يعني كانه هو نفس البراند
بس مره ملثم مره لابس بدله مره انما هي في
الحقيقه في الاخر هي نفس العقليه اللي هي
عقليه استغباء المشاهدين وان انت تبيع لهم
كلمه جيده او عباره جيده او او حركه وكان
مصائر الناس ابتدت تتحول لاعلانات
[موسيقى]
تلفزيونيه ختاما هل هو هناك اطماع
لاسرائيل في دول عربيه غير فلسطين نعم اذا
قرانا التراث والتاريخ بعنايه واذا اخذنا
تصريحات نتنياهو الدافن الاخيره بجديه
ووعده بتحقيق نبوءه اسرائيل الكبرى في
المقابل هل هناك اطماع للفلسطينيين
باحتلال دول عربيه كلا ولا يقول بذلك عاقل
اذا لماذا لا تتمتع المقا
الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
بحاضنة
الخناجر ولا حكم النادل
فيا ياما مويل
[موسيقى]
الهواى